man nennt mich auch den nudeln könig der
umkleide vielleicht sah
hey leute doch trainer und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video vor das
war richtig gut
und bevor wir hier weitermachen ist es
natürlich super wichtig dass die ersten
zu den kanal abonniert und zweitens die
glocke aktiviert weil ihr kommt jeden
tag um 19 uhr ein neues video und wenn
ihr das nicht macht dann passiert euch
nein das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen aber
macht einfach okay ganz ganz wichtig
dankeschön
tja leute ich habe mir meine köchin
lassen wer dabei und zwar kamen wir auf
die geniale idee wäre mein letztes mal
so im kopf wie du gemacht hast mir
wollten wir diese gemüse reis vorne
gemacht und hier meinte hey clusters und
gericht kochen aus nur der gleichen
farbe
dann habe ich gedacht diese machst du
eigentlich keinen youtube-videos weil
auf diese idee hätte auch da hätten auch
die brainforce com mit gamers gamer also
dort eben schon praktisch angemacht von
diesem ganzen zeug dass wir gekauft
haben hätte ich wirklich fünf mal
bestellen können das hat computing euro
etwas und war so alleinige wo sie habe
erstmals ein mix jugendwehren mixa der
24 euro kostet dann brauchen wir wohl
für den nachtisch und will so dann haben
wir hier rote chili ok meine aber wenn
du keine ahnung
die teilnahme ist für den nachtisch das
ist das einzige was halt nicht das geld
plötzlich und als ich jetzt haben wir
die rote paprika dann kann man immer
sehr gut mitarbeiten ich weiß jetzt auch
schon wieder eine paprika schneidet dann
haben wir eine bilanz aber positiv und
die zwiebel betreten und das heißt hier
so sagt man auch blaue so setzen
das sind
diese möbel die ich noch nie zuvor in
meinem leben gefunden habt gute linden
und rote linsen makkaroni sind das ist
auch von mir folgen ja ok und zu guter
letzt haben wir hier für den nachrichten
erfahren und werde ich das heißt er wir
starten braucht wahrscheinlich wieder
noch ne fahne kann er jetzt kommt ein
bisschen salz in die brühe oder kann
weiß ich ja schon
und ganz wichtig hier also cannes lief
zu viel salz sei also das eigentlich
egal
willst du das nicht vorstellen dass er
schon ich wollte jetzt auch noch einmal
auf
ich habe besser was mich dort masters
ist nutzen wir auch so gemacht
das letzte mal mich das gar nicht
irgendwie gemacht ja genauso kümmern
sich noch richtig so
gleich werden dazu und jetzt mache ich
das jetzt immer alex fort dass hinter
jedem video wird immer besser
das habe ich halt auch noch nie gesehen
das ist resultat ist bei den profiköchen
so gesehen also jetzt passen aufgaben
als die hälfte geschnitten nach mehr
einfach so und jetzt auf und wie schnell
wir hier noch kleinen stimmt ja dann
kann man wie schnell das ging war das
jetzt eine gute variante oder eine gute
bewertung ist gar nicht mal so gut
marica ist fertig die rote paprika sehr
gut gemacht alles danke und wir machen
jetzt mit der bibel vor sich am besten
machen server wegschmeißen
außerdem sind jetzt wo ist das denn roth
erste große zwiebeln ja okay wir machen
heute pflaster arrabiata schönen
tomatensoße
ein bisschen schade genauso inhalt
nudeln dazu ich wollte noch keiner
machen und rein mit solider das wasser
brutzeln was machen wir als nächstes im
elektro und die sind jetzt gefragt wie
dein gesicht kommt der beiname jahren
gehabt habe drohungen
die wollten ja wir farbenblind seite
aber das ist orange nein das ist besteht
hier rot oder orange rote linsen genau
heißt ja nicht dass das ding gut ist
dass wir es gibt für meinen daumen
runter von mir
man nennt mich auch den nudeln könig der
umkleide vielleicht macht immer weiter
ich den kurzen flug ab
rein damit in die pfanne
leute wir waren direkt ist auch hier die
passierten tomaten dazu weil man sollte
nicht zu lange warten
und ja deswegen mag ich es jetzt hast du
dir alles klar kommt die ganze packung
ja komplett die ganze packung ja
metzger mit namen geburtstag und dazu
ganz wichtig noch das lässt sich aus
okay leute mögen ministerin design ab
damit ganz schön heißt so heißt ein
probieren ja mal probieren wir mal ein
kleines bisschen von der soße das riecht
sehr italienisch gut dass mich meine
nudeln dazu schon kommen überlasst man
mir diese sorge ich bin ein profi koch
ja okay das wurde jetzt um manövriert in
den topf auf anweisung von suri sieht
doch schon lecker kann man auf jeden
fall sinn machen
ok dann würde ich sagen wir können jetzt
schon mit der nachtisch fortfahren oder
genauso wie ich tue mich auch sofort
fahren so wir kommen schon mal zum
nachtisch und damit zum frisch gekauften
nicht ganz stimmt ihr nicht vergessen so
meine damen und herren für den nachtisch
haben wir diesen wunderschönen mixa
ich hoffe dass ich hier eine gute stadt
bekommen wir kann immer noch da
also leute hier haben wir jetzt drin
erdbeeren gefroren eine banane und milch
und das wird jetzt der smoothie okay so
was habe ich glaube ich noch nie
wirklich gemacht
so wir haben es noch ein paar frische
erdbeeren zu danken wir das wollten
was haben wir uns mal richtig von mir
also hinzugefügt und jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt
das lass mich mal versuchen ob ich das
jetzt rein krieg sagt nein
war schon ganz gut
hier findet das jetzt um ihr den
leckeren smoothie wir zuerst einmal
selber gemacht habt okay wenn ich also
so wie wolf biermann vom doping und wir
haben jetzt die himbeeren und ausgesucht
dann haben wir doch cranberries und dann
noch das ding kann ganz viel geld aber
ein paar erdbeeren kommt auch noch es
trotzdem
also eigentlich sind die cranberries so
schön rot wie auf der verpackung aber
irgendwie jetzt am hauptportal mir
gesehen dass die doch ziemlich dunkel
sand in dieser vorschau angeguckt weil
man muss schon sagen bei mir auf dem
kanal kommen wie es davor angenehmen
kochen
also ich habe mich in letzter zeit jetzt
so gesteigert ok so und was machen wir
damit jetzt endlich fertig stößt du
schon mal zum tisch ja so reicht schon
über die situation wollen wir das wär
das schön wer das jetzt noch mal zur
erklärung
das alles sollte zwei löffel holen die
beiden eine gabel und löffel und einen
löffel für die bau etwas macht alle ach
so warten wir jetzt mal wieder einmal in
die comments hashtag ware queen leute
also wir sind jetzt so weiter mit dem
roten essen ich bin da ist eigentlich
ganz gut aus so weil man hier bei den
nudeln mehl ich sagen muss dieses
kontinents rot also ja besser als
normale nudeln definitiv sind auf dem
fall geht schon ein bisschen ins rote
rein ansonsten richtig gut wir wollten
ja nicht forschungsmittel farbe arbeiten
wenn ihr sagt er macht das bitte auch
nur mit gelben sachen geht man doch nach
oben ne ganz wichtig und wir starten
jetzt mal mit der probe hier
ach so das hier ist übrigens kirschsaft
habe ich noch dazu geholt also
aber das müsst ihr eure mütter haben
geschmeckt ach so heißt also man
schmeckt abhilfe
wer sowas gerne mag hier habe die lösung
sofort auf dem objektiv druck das hat
echt noch schärfere konkurs um den witz
zu erklären auf dem objektiv vorne dazu
sagt man auch die linse das wissen dass
die leute nicht wie manche vielleicht
nicht mehr aber sonst ich würde sagen
dadurch dass wir keine kräuter nehmen
durften so das ist jetzt nicht so die
geschmacksexplosion und aber
7 ich muss aber ganz ehrlich sagen wir
sind linsen nudeln beim mindestlohn als
recht bisschen wahrscheinlich legal oder
so also von mir gibt es da auch liegt
gemeinde schließlich die an sieben von
zehn punkte höher
otto jetzt glaube ich hiermit
weitermachen und wir direkt auf die
konsistenz man durch ein bisschen
exklusiver sollen genau das ist ja ich
weiss nicht wahrscheinlich doch ein
bisschen zu viel milch gewesen und man
kann ja nicht mal schlimm das zulässig
ich finde das so viel milch drin
ja es könnte ja da muss man echt drauf
achten dass man nichts jetzt nämlich von
geschmacklich und sagt okay so zahlreich
dass lag ich wollte nämlich vollkommen
zurück alles gut 36 prozent aber mehr
ist nicht drin steckt fest geschlossen
hat kann sich schon sehr flüssig
geschmacklich könnte ich sagen eine art
und er aber gesagt konsistenz halte echt
ein bisschen dickflüssiger sein kann ja
heute das mit dem koch video wir essen
das jetzt natürlich noch keine frage ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen schreibt die
welt schreibt die nächste farbe in die
kommentare
wenn ihr mögt und die normalerweise geht
auf jeden fall nach oben und das war es
blogger aktivieren abonnieren ganz ganz
wichtig ja